okay so about 30 or 40 maybe 50 years
ago my father who's a bartender brought
for me a saloon sign a beer sign a neon
beer sign for Ballantine ale and beer
I mean it's within the unsign been in my
attic for decades you know there's
something cool about the Ballantine logo
it used to say purity body in flavor I
hauled this out of the Attic got a neon
sign transformer up and figure hey I got
a light this up throw a switch and hot
damn Ballantine ale and beer the
beautiful thing is this is the neon
representation of a Borromean ring the
cool thing about a Borromean or as some
people say a boram in ring is it's a
knot that's not a knot
one circle another circle and another
circle intersect and you can't tear them
apart from one another
this can't be removed from this can't be
removed from this and yet they don't
even have to touch one another as an
aside you can prove that you can't make
this out of three perfect circles don't
intersect these three circles purity
body and flavor are interlinked under
over under over under over under over
the of course the nan is a cheat look at
this it goes under over over over over
under and on so it's a projection of the
Borromean rings onto the front window of
a saloon they had to do this the neon
sign maker couldn't make a neon sign
that had these correct without pretty
much standing on their head partly
because making three circles that
intersect like this you can show that
they can't be plainer circles they have
to be up at some point or another each
of them has to be slightly out of the
plane
which is gonna be a challenge for Annie
honor it is to be you can do that yep
notice how this guy is out of the plane
and this this cheat entirely they should
really go under and back over and then
down so moreover I'd have to do it
electrically with three different
circuits each ring of course would need
to be a separate electrical device
because these aren't electrically
connected they're not physically
touching one another here I've got every
electron going through this letter e
goes through all three of these almost
circles and then continues on to the b
and b r the cheat of course is they want
it to look like it's right and that's
good enough to attract people to hang
out the bait in front of the bar neon
people are clever look look what they've
done with letters like the letter A
Euler's topology suggests that the
letter A should not be a makeable letter
happily people who make neon don't
listen to topologists more than that
they don't keep their entire neon sign
in to space they're perfectly happy to
use three space and project their
message onto the two space of the window
and ultimately onto the two space of our
retinas meanwhile I got this wonderful
gift someone gave me a hot glue gun and
I'm playing with this hot glue gun I
realized hey you know I can use this to
attach check this out to glue magnets
onto strings so that I can make strings
that hook up to one another
mathematically this isn't a knot it only
becomes a knot when the ends are
connected so a mathematical not must
have continuity this is called the
unknot it's a circle the unknot can be
wrapped around itself you know it's not
obvious now that this isn't uh not
but it is an overhand knot like this
this is not yet a knot but becomes a
knot when I connect the ends together so
here's an overhand or a trefoil knot
mathematical trefoil knot okay so I made
three strings that have magnets on e and
I want to make Bora main rings let's go
over here under here below here below
here above here above here above there
below there connect these now let's make
this one the bottom one this one goes up
there this one goes up here and although
it's not as beautiful as the neon not
here's a Baroni and ring over under over
under the skies over under over under
this kind of the purple one over under
over under
now what's wonderfully neat is these are
completely linked with one another but
disconnecting any one makes everything
fall apart so I'll disconnect just the
purple and the other two although still
tied to one another fall out
the Borromean rings require each other
in order to form these links if you can
find a blue gun a couple magnets and a
couple pieces of string you've got it
made there's there's all the ingredients
that you need to explore knot theory but
meanwhile I'm saying well I'm playing
with these knots I can look over at the
at the knots of neon from a beer company
well I said over to the glass shop and I
say oh I'll make a knot out of neon my
friend Lucas Clark makes a neon not
which as far as I know they're kind of
rare he makes a neo not out of out of
tubing and as you can see it's not a
true not remember how real knots have to
have their ends connected so this looks
to some people to be a knot but in fact
it's homeomorphic to a cylinder unless
you're an electron if your electron you
have to travel in an entire circuit
through a transformer and back to the
other way so to an electron it's enough
to my eyeball ah it's still cool looking
well how did you dad
he died 22 years 32 years ago well cliff
I'm cliff jr. he was a wonderful man the
kind of my dad uh he lived to be around
his kids all he cared about was having
fun with his kids so okay Brady so I'm
six years old my father comes home from
the bar or he's worked a long time he
starts drinking some beer and I say hey
Dad can I have some of your beer he says
nah when you're older so I turned 12 13
years old we're listening the radio
together I turned to my father and say
dad can I have some beer he said you're
only 12 you can't have beer the day I
turned 18 when I went to the draft board
got my draft registration came home said
dad can I have some beer now my father
says no not right now I'll tell you when
it's okay well I never asked him again
in my whole life I've never had a drop
of alcohol you never had a beer wine
vodka nothing but I can't see a beer
sign I can't see an advertisement for a
wine or liquor without thinking
wonderful thoughts about my father
so it's going back in the Attic now my
wife and I put it in our front window
for a few days
entertain our neighborhood people
started coming up on her porch banging
out door saying where's the beer